regarding the human enjoyment of
birdsong
could it relate to our ancestral
reliance on bird language to alert us to
danger
some birds and primates react to each
other's predator alarms song mean
means all's well oh that's great yeah
that is that is beautiful
um in most places where humans have done
well there are
songbirds and yes we would have begun to
listen to them so you know we're
effectively part the hypothesis here is
that we're part of their mixed foraging
flocks
uh and that even though we aren't uh
contributing anything obvious to them um
maybe
we are listening for their song just as
they are watching for our signs of alarm
and we will um all be alarmed together
if something
happens yep i like it and uh
by inducing you to pay attention to
birdsong it could cause you to know when
birdsong has changed and you know you
can hear
lots of things squirrels for example
will alert you to something
you know that they regard as hazardous
yeah um
usually not the same thing as a person
regards as hazardous no
in general a lower bar i do remember i'm
trying to remember which
student it was i had a student
write a paper on the concept of
um whether there's this pattern of
people uh hunter-gatherers keeping pets
right taking forest creatures and hand
raising them and the question was
whether this was providing them
basically access to the sensory systems
of these creatures that by
developing an empathic bond that that
creature then provides them
an ability to see into the world the way
you know dogs provide us the ability to
detect scents that we can't ourselves
smell
so anyway yeah there's something to it
also it might explain some of the really
weird
behavior that every so often somebody
will post a clip of
i saw one just a couple days ago
it was a magpie was ushering
might have been a hedgehog across a road
and it was clear that this is what the
animal was doing that the
magpie was coming up behind the hedgehog
and urging it across the road
right and you know well the
interpretation is up for grabs but
yeah um magpies are i think corvids
and so corvids being crows and jays uh
and a few others and
ravens uh you know super smart you know
just
more theory of mind than you know other
corvids and parrots and then a
smattering of mammal clades have theory
of mind
um and they seem to be able to empathize
outside of clade apparently helping a
hedgehog well
it's also impossible that we're entering
it to a call to dinner or something yeah
but
uh he will be the guest of honor but you
know there are
examples of partnerships between
creatures you know honey guides and
people
are a good example there are natural
examples of this where
uh there's a partnering and in fact
mixed foraging flocks
if you're foraging on different things
you can afford to have
effectively a school of birds as it were
that's larger
than it would be if they were all your
type and competing for the same food
resource
or even i mean um you know i think it's
uh
boy like chickadees and kinglets in the
pacific northwest that engage in these
winter mixed foraging flocks
in which i don't remember which it is
but one of them they feed on very much
the same winter berries actually
but they're very partially distributed
and one of the species is much better at
finding and the other species is much
better at
having sentries and watching out for
predators and so they actually
are competing for the same resource but
together they're both specialists
on something that each of them need yeah
yeah wow that's cool
[Music]
you